je m'appelle pâtit bledel et je ne suis
pas l'exemple type de la reine de beauté
il ya des choses que je n'aurais changé
chez moi je ne
c'est la mama la plus incroyable que
j'ai jamais vu ça a l'air horrible être
magnifique et avoir un copain super
canon l'apparence n'a aucune importance
madeline et après merdier je suspecte
dans une enquête pour meurtre
quoi ouais t'as tué quelqu'un non bien
sûr que non
rien de changé qu'il suit qui est une
fête ne laisse pas le passé de tirer en
arrière on en a fini avec les époques
je rêve où les partis c'est une période
compliquée pour elle
du coup j'avais décidé de reprendre le
contrôle de ma vie mais je ne voulais
pas penser à la mort à la destruction
il fallait que je ne focalise sur mon
avenir qu'elle quittait ce que je
pouvais faire d'autre
[Applaudissements]
les filles de pardonneront d'être
déboutant cité pendant dois dire que je
me lasserai jamais cette visite je
connais pas tu y es capable de beaucoup
de choses mais pas de tuer
[Musique]
ou alors tu vois
ça va être chouette impressionnant vous
avez été gros dément
[Musique]